so what about what about your what's
your take on this Justin as far as uh
you know becoming a millionaire some of
the
secrets
yeah so first obviously you want to
educate yourself you can do that through
books you can do that through YouTubes
but at some point you have to pay to put
yourself in a room with other
like-minded people that also pay them to
be in that room you know I often say
this there was a story one time where my
operations manager she asked me she goes
Justin you know
don't you think you've paid to go enough
of these events and I said you don't
understand I might learn one or two
things I might not learn anything but
what I can't replace is pain to be in
the room with other like-minded people
that also paid to be in that room so it
gets rid of a lot of [ __ ] when
you're able to pay to be in a room full
of people it's the same thing as why
when I give someone something or when
you give someone something it's better
to make them even charge them a few
dollars so that they have like some skin
in the game rather than just giving
someone something for free because it's
like oh I paid for this like I'm gonna
take it more seriously but yeah that's
the idea and normally that is the
correct answer I I have a couple of
thoughts on this so generally speaking
I've been to a few networking things
where you know you had to pay get taught
I know some people who are kind of
addicted to it and they just jump from
they go to one program and they're like
yeah I'm gonna change my life and then
they don't do [ __ ] and then they jump to
another program and yeah I'm going to
change my life and then they don't do
[ __ ] and so what this guy is saying I
think is that you know he goes to war
room events and goes to more and more
and more of those and he just keeps
getting deeper and his Network and
relationships get deeper and that's
where you find success don't become an
education addict where you're all over
the place and you actually end up
accomplishing [ __ ] right this guy is
getting it sounds like he's really
getting something out of it and growing
from it so and I think it's an important
distinction that people don't understand
yeah like out of the gate I'd agree that
also can pay to be in that room because
it excludes the people that you don't
need so you can get in a room where the
cream is risen so very very important to
network obviously you want to educate
yourself so you can make money once you
educate yourself in a place that you can
make money then you want to pay to be in
the room with other people you can
network with and that's when your net
worth really starts to grow I think your
high school friends are going to hold
you back and you need to some people in
the chat are saying like why would you
pay to go be in these rooms but this is
the place we're going to find
like-minded peoples online
yeah this isn't like going into a
fraternity and paying for people to
drink with yeah drink and get Haze like
yeah I know it's so funny how stuff like
the war room and you know sneako's
creativity it and my you know get [ __ ]
done Academy it all gets you know [ __ ]
on because you have to pay to join like
a group and a network and to learn but I
don't know it just it doesn't make sense
because then you'll go and you can be a
frat kid and pay thousands of dollars a
semester just to get hammered I guess in
either case in both cases you're going
into a group of like-minded people and
do you want to be the like-minded people
that it's like yeah well I'm just gonna
get wasted for the next four years or do
you want to be the like-minded people
that say yeah we're going to grow
Empires over the next four years and so
there's similarities but the outcomes
are totally different chats oh yeah no I
was gonna say I was talking I was
speaking in sneakers creativity kit
shout out to snico and his program it's
awesome I definitely recommend it but um
we were just talking about that how
someone asked us like what do you
recommend doing to surround yourself
with successful people and we said to do
that online you know that's outdated
where you just like look around the
block and people in your neighborhood to
become successful with if you're really
looking to become successful with people
you look online and you join networks
and you continuously pay and join groups
that's what I did and that's how I made
my first you know yeah and you'll find
the right people you'll find that right
I got mine through affiliate marketing
for a larger server and then me and the
other guys who are all doing the best
ended up starting our own thing so you
just got to keep making connections
online I haven't done any business with
people in person you know I just got
this book I haven't read it yet called
find your six it's by this guy Patrick
Kilner I think his name is and uh it's
really about that it's about finding the
his philosophy is there are six people
in the world who are going to take you
where you're gonna go and you have to
find them and you have to be obviously
as we talk about all the time be really
deliberate about who those people are as
sad it is your high school friends will
hold you back because the only reason
you're really with them is because you
grew up with them and you went to school
with them and obviously like they're you
know they can be good people but a lot
of the time all you're doing is smoking
and playing video games and bullshitting
around together you're not actually
making any steps to better yourself
maybe you're going to the gym once in a
while but if you're really serious about
becoming successful you got to surround
yourself with people who are really
trying to get that you know what I mean
yeah I mean otherwise you're just going
to be the guy in the room who rolls the
best joint and I've uh no I'm not I'm
the only non-millionaire here but I'm
well on the way and Chris is going to
definitely throw me a party when I get
there but you're right there because of
that um because of these networks and
because of people I've met online
through like-minded people and not just
staying to the same community that I've
met since I was maybe 12. that's how
I've been able to 10x my income is
through online communities it's really
it's really real and the more that
people hold it back and the more people
talk down at it the more you're really
wasting the opportunities that are right
in front of you you need to get in these
rooms you need to get them money so that
you can meet an online community full of
people that are in the same page even
going to college yeah you're paying to
go to college but everyone goes to
college you're not like it's like you're
paying to get into a more exclusive
group if you're paying and to get into a
group where everyone's trying to better
themselves you're automatically taking a
better step and you're surrounding
yourself with like-minded people that
are all trying to become successful but
going to college people are just going
to college to go to college it's not
like they're going to like really grind
and like you know this is my four years
to to educate myself like no one even
thinks like that that's not what college
is for anymore excuse me I know it used
to be that way where your family you
know would send you across the ocean to
go to a college you know and there are
people there is that that top few
percent I don't know what the number is
of creme de La Creme students who are
going to go in and they're going to
become scientists and really create
something that helps the world and
they're driven yeah the rest of them are
just a monster bunch of yeah schlabs
like I was not judging just speaking
fast yeah first couple months of school
I was getting you know I was partying a
lot but I also like worked a lot during
the day and I was still like running up
my bags and I made like rules with
myself you know I had my rule I told you
about I would only go out for once every
thousand dollars I made then I started
making bank yeah and then I started
going out more when you're a girl Justin
do you have like how'd you get this type
of information I mean me and you were
kind of from the same area but how'd you
get it no man you didn't I mean first of
all you had to read a book hardback you
know like old school wise yep I remember
the first time I read Rich that poor dad
I was a junior in college we're going to
play Arkansas I read it on the bus you
know and then that [ __ ] blows your mind
now the first time sort of getting
information through that and then the
world has absolutely changed in the last
10 years you can actually not only
find out about ways to get more
Consciousness more education on how to
grow yourself but you can actually be in
touch with these people now which is
which I feel like has changed a lot in
the last few years with the groups man
so networking is more how do I say this
it's more available than it has ever
been and it's the biggest gift that any
young man could ever have and whether
you know it or not you must figure out
how to take advantage of it okay cool uh
Michael mestroke super sticker uh two
bucks thank you so much and guys bear
with me here man I'm doing a bunch of
things behind the scenes Richard Florida
is such a good book that was my first
business book that I ever read Russian
goes hello from Turkey shots of turkey
man
um and then we also got um
let's see here I'm going to turn it to
snico Ethan Lenhart goes good evening
gentlemen I'm 21 I've been married 10
months I have realized that I cannot
become the man I was uh to become while
married to this woman any advice to be
appreciated all summer and how accurate
is sicario um it's not accurate at all
because
um the FBI doesn't really investigate uh
cartel crime like that I mean they do
every now and then bro but it's really
HSI that takes a league when it comes to
transnational criminal organizations uh
guys what are your thoughts on this man
and guys we're going to be oh it's one
of the kick shows off the girls q and
A's on this screen about the show um you
know get your good questions because
he's saying I'm 21 and I've been married
10 months I've realized I can't become
the man I was to become well married to
this woman it's you know any advice
would be appreciated if this guy ends up
watching this or first of all there's
not enough information to really give
give good advice but overall if you do
decide to break up this marriage do it
like a gentleman be a man sit down or
talk to her about it the conversation
she may be the actually she may be the
woman that you need her stop it she
it's not it's actually just Seltzer and
a little tequila I'm not even like
drinking a lot for the love of God so
you know she may be the good woman and
she is a solid woman who just hasn't
finished growing up yet Jesus they're
21. yeah maybe she yeah first of all I
got married at 20. have a real
conversation and really dig deep and try
try with her and if you can't leave like
a gentleman say I'm sorry we're young we
made a mistake and but if there are
children be a man make sure she's taken
care of put that woman and child above
yourself and take care of her look how
bright we are we look like ghosts that's
because I we're listen once we get to
Florida we're gonna have nice Tans
things are going to be better that's
because the light is on it's not that
Moon mode it is not stop complaining you
see what I mean no complaining about
someone getting married and not finding
the right Community yeah basically right
here you said that it's a waste of time
and it's going to hold you back the time
that you spend is the most important and
you need to really prioritize that
that's something I've realized and
something that I've been able to to
Really 10x micro past three months is
from information like this people in the
chat are saying right now I went from
watching Tate's videos to being in the
Tate studio and that's because I've been
putting myself in the right situations
I've been putting myself around the
right people putting spreading the right
message and it's really proof that if
you put out the correct energy then it
comes back to you so if you're spending
time with a woman in a marriage that's
holding you back and you're wasting your
time you're having arguments yeah what
are you even doing then she's draining
your energy right and he's assuming
because he's assuming arguments in which
case we've got to really realize in the
past three months and that's why the
next time you see this podcast maybe in
like six months I will be a
multi-millionaire Bam
um any other thoughts on this question
here guys he said he basically had to
get away from the girl uh because he
couldn't grow with her well uh I
actually was in that scenario myself and
um you know I married a single mom like
I said before and you know I thought I
was holding back because once again I
would step down once again and I was
taking care of a kid that wasn't mine my
energy went towards that you know being
a good husband so to speak and you know
what I can't say America
well as you know what if I keep on his
path I aren't going to be where I want
to be decided to swallow a hard pill one
thing was coming from work doing on
YouTube found Tom Leykis bought um key
riches found solo tv84 Rollo as well and
like those videos changed my life
because I say you know what I'm not
where I want to be how do I change and
the best thing I could do is break up
with her and I had to so at home that
day broke up with her and because of
that event that happened where I broke
up with her I'm here today so guys yeah
at some point you gotta realize that put
yourself first you don't put yourself
first you can't win yeah
uh just anything on that or oh man
that's it if you can't put yourself
first she's not gonna respect you anyway
man oh no who's Fred no no actually
there's two Fred stories about two
different friends but I'm just gonna go
with one right now because it's relevant
so Fred was he was he was like an uncle
to me he worked for uh my my parents my
parents had a business for 35 years and
he worked for them the whole time so he
was at our dinner table almost every
night so he was like an uncle to me and
I was about to say I'm glad he's dead
but it's not that I'm glad he's dead I'm
not I just I'm glad he's not gonna hear
me you know talking about his personal
[ __ ] on the internet but he definitely
won't I learned this as a little girl
and I always found it fascinating he was
married in his Youth and he one night
was just sitting there watching TV with
the wife and there were no kids and he
said to her I'm gonna go out for a pack
of smokes and he got up and he left the
house and he just never went back you
got milk he went for milk he went for
cigarettes and he Fred smoked a lot and
he just he just never ever ever went
back and as an adult now I don't know if
they ever formalize the divorce I don't
know whatever happened I just know he
bolted he just dipped like a country
song just I'm out of here this is in
Brooklyn I mean and I just think it's
fascinating so that is an option not
anymore not with social media and your
online presence back then you just moved
Two Towns over yeah nobody ever had to
find you again yeah yeah so it I just
think it's it's an interesting it's it's
an option some places interesting Fred
he was such a good guy falcon
[Music]
one